das sind zwei absolut spektakuläre
thesen die dunkle materie besteht aus
schwarzen löchern und eins davon ist in
unserem sonnensystem und dazu noch ich
konnte mit dem autor dieser absolut
spektakulären studie eine exklusive
interview führen den wissenschaftlichen
direktor der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur esa astrophysiker
professor günther hasinger hier also ein
video dass unser weltbild verändern wird
krieg zum science and future bis dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts lustig
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen so das ist jetzt der
absolute wahnsinn die theorie der
dunklen materie fällt hier gerade den
schwarzen löchern zum opfer und wir wir
hatten ja schon mal darüber berichtet
denn was ein wenig verblüffend ist die
artikel über dunkle materie und schwarze
löcher auf wikipedia fangen ziemlich
ähnlich an aber das ist nur ein indiz
ganz am rande aber bisher gab es einfach
zu wenige schwarze löcher um die dunkle
materie damit zu erklären das ist jetzt
anders
ja also wir finden eben eigentlich an
allen möglichen stellen schwarzen löcher
wo wir sie bisher nicht vermutet haben
günther hasinger ist nicht irgendwer der
deutsche astrophysiker ist seit ende
2017 direktor für den bereich
wissenschaft bei der europäischen
weltraumorganisation esa und somit
koordiniert er forschungsprojekte von
mehr als 500 wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern zusammen mit seinem
forschungsteam am institut für
astronomie der universität hawaii hatte
er unter anderem das mysteriöse rund 400
meter lange objekt entdeckt dass von der
form her an eine zigarre erinnert und
das die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler dann oben hua nannten
das spezialgebiet und die absolute
leidenschaft von günther hasinger aber
ist die röntgenastronomie in den
vergangenen jahren hat er an einigen
röntgen satelliten mitgearbeitet und
deren daten ausgewertet dazu hatte er
selbst mal vor zwei jahren gesagt meine
größte leistung war dass ich mit diesen
satelliten sehr sehr lange auf
irgendwelche leeren flecken am himmel
geschaut und dabei tausende schwarze
löcher entdeckt habe und genau das
bringt den astrophysiker jetzt dazu eine
wirklich spannende
und äußerst waghalsige these
aufzustellen die im krassen gegensatz zu
der klassischen urknalltheorie steht
kurz gesagt geht günther hasinger davon
aus gleich mehrere der zahlreichen
geheimnisse da draußen im universum
gelüftet zu haben
dabei sieht der schwarze löcher mit
völlig anderen augen als alle anderen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vor ihm sind diese mysteriösen objekte
denen wir bislang noch nie so richtig
auf die schliche kommen konnten also die
antwort auf mehrere bislang ungelöste
rätsel des universums sein aktueller
aufsatz ist jetzt im fachmagazin journal
of cosmology und erste particle physics
erschienen und im großen und ganzen
beschreibt der physiker hier eine
alternative entstehungsgeschichte von
sternen und galaxien
denn er ist davon überzeugt dass zuerst
schwarze löcher entstanden sind und zwar
nur wenige sekunden nach dem urknall
die rechnung die ich dann angestellt war
wenn es diese prix medialen schwarze
löcher gibt also wenn die in den ersten
zwei sekunden nach dem urknall
entstanden sind dann flitzen die durch
die normale materie durch die normale
materie fällt dann auch ab und zu mal
drauf und erzeugt bricht es ist ein
schwarzes loch verrät sich ja dadurch
dass der letzte hilfeschrei der materie
kurz bevor es drauf fällt
reinfeldt und dann für immer
verschwunden ist der letzte hilfeschrei
wird in form verdrängten und infrarot
strahlung ausgesendet und das können wir
sehen eine absolut bahnbrechende these
und sie ist eben mit daten belegt man
kann sie durch die materie die in
seefeld sehen hammer dass günther
hasinger als alter hase und
wissenschafts direkter der esa überhaupt
selbst noch aktuelle forschung betreibt
hängt mit der aktuellen corona zeit
zusammen er hält sich nämlich nicht an
seinem eigentlichen sitz in madrid auf
sondern ihr in berlin wo ich ihn
getroffen habe und dort hatte er zeit
sich mit dem spannendsten thema
überhaupt auseinander zu setzen
dem ursprung der schwarzen löcher unter
anderem analysiert der tag für tag und
nacht für nacht die daten und ergebnisse
die er während seiner karriere mit hilfe
des keck observatoriums auf hawaii um
mithilfe von weltraumteleskopen erlangt
hat im fokus seiner analyse aber standen
die messung die der amerikanischen
sandra geliefert hatte bereits vor
einigen jahren gelangen könnte
mit diesem erdumkreisung observateur
bereits eine äußerst spannende
entdeckung und zwar spürte er röntgen
signale auf die seiner analyse zufolge
von besonders massereichen schwarzen
löchern ausgegangen waren mit hilfe von
chandra hatten die fachleute tatsächlich
eine art strahlungsmesser aufgefangen
diese entstanden dann wenn die
supermassiven schwarzen löcher alles das
verstand was ihnen zu nahe kam und das
war eine ganze menge an staub und gas
und bei seinen analysen stellte der
astrophysiker etwas ungewöhnliches fest
die röntgenblitze waren seinen
berechnungen zufolge bereits in der
frühzeit des universums ausgesandt
worden
laut der klassischen rock mal theorie
kann das aber keinesfalls so sein denn
demnach entstehen schwarze löcher aus
uralten ausgebrannten sternen aber
zahlreiche beobachtungen können nur mit
primor die ahlen schwarzen löchern also
schwarzen löchern erklärt werden die
kurz nach dem urknall entstanden sind
also es gibt einfach an verschiedensten
stellen phänomene die wir uns nicht
erklären können wo schwarze löcher eine
rolle spielen die da sind wo es
eigentlich nicht sein sollten
und diese primär die alten daher könnten
das alles erklären kurz noch mal zum
verständnis laut der klassischen urknall
theorie ist das universum quasi aus dem
nichts entstanden ganz am anfang war es
kleiner als ein atom eine ultra heiße
energie kugeln blitzte plötzlich auf und
entwickelte sich in rasender
geschwindigkeit zu einer kosmischen
größe
dabei entstanden dann auch zeit und raum
die plasma suppe erkaltete nach und nach
und es bildet sich materie schwaben aus
denen dann sonnen und planeten
hervorgingen doch auch sterne werden
nicht nur geboren sondern sterben auch
wegen der extremen schwerkraft fallen
die sterne
nach ihrem langen leben in sich zusammen
wenn sie keinen brennstoff mehr haben um
die kernfusion aufrechtzuerhalten die
verhindert dass die sterne zu einem
schwarzen loch zusammenfallen zurück zu
den aktuellen forschungsergebnissen von
günther hasinger denn nicht nur über das
hohe alter der schwarzen löcher extrem
verwundert war denn auch die extreme
masse der schwarzen löcher ist laut den
bisherigen ansichten der wissenschaft
nicht wirklich nachzuvollziehen
demnach verschlucken schwarze löcher
zwar unablässig staub und gas doch
müsste es eigentlich ja milliarden
dauern wie sie so extrem massereiche
werden beide beobachtungen machten
günther hasinger also extrem stutzig
seiner ansicht nach kann es dafür nur
eine erklärung geben
schwarze löcher entstehen demnach also
gar nicht ausschließlich aus sterbenden
sternen sondern direkt aus der urmaterie
vor allem in den regionen in denen
besonders viel urmaterie herum waberte
konnten sich also schwarze löcher bilden
davon ist günther hasinger überzeugt er
ist sich sicher dass schwarze löcher im
gerade frisch entstanden und universum
die ersten und für eine lange zeit auch
die einzigen himmelskörper waren wow
physikalisch gesehen ist das übrigens
durchaus vorstellbar das gesamte
szenario wäre denkbar wenn sich die
materie bereits in den ersten zwei
sekunden nach dem urknall in schwarze
löcher verwandelt hätte dabei könnten
schwarze löcher verschiedenster größen
entstanden sein mini kleine löcher nur
einige zentimeter groß aber auch extrem
große schwarze löcher falls günther
hasinger damit tatsächlich recht
behalten sollte wäre das eine riesige
sensation die unser komplettes bild des
universums über den haufen werfen würde
und zwar mit weitreichenden konsequenzen
einer von beispielsweise wäre dass es
sogar in unserer milchstraße von
schwarzen löchern nur so wimmeln müsste
laut dem astrophysiker könnten es sogar
mehr als sichtbare sterne seien sie
wären überall schwarze löcher könnten
uns also viel näher sein als wir bislang
angenommen hatten und tatsächlich hatten
bereits studien ergebnisse aus der
vergangenheit darauf hingewiesen
in diesem kontext gab es anfang diesen
jahres sogar noch eine spektakuläre
entdeckung ein gigantisches
schwerkraftmonster direkt in unserer
kosmischen nachbarschaft den fachleuten
zufolge handelt es sich hierbei um ein
schwarzes loch das nur 1000 lichtjahre
von der erde entfernt ist dazu schreibt
das autorenteam wir waren völlig
überrascht als wir feststellten dass
dies das erste sternsystem mit einem
schwarzen loch ist dass man mit bloßem
auge sehen kann dieses system enthält
das der erde nächstgelegene schwarze
loch von dem wir wissen bei dieser
entdeckung handelte sich also um eine
echte premiere und um das nächstgelegene
schwarze loch das jemals aufgespürt
werden konnte und das obwohl uns eine
distanz von 1000 lichtjahren trend im
wirklich unvorstellbar großen weltall
ist diese strecke aber wirklich minimal
und umfasst gerade einmal unsere
erweiterten nachbarschaft das wird sehr
gut deutlich im vergleich mit dem
schwarzen loch namens sayed ali shah
stern das im zentrum der milchstraße
schlummert dafür gab es ja gerade den
physik-nobelpreis also für die
entdeckung die entfernung zur erde
beträgt in diesem fall ganze 26 tausend
lichtjahre und diese spektakuläre
entdeckung könnte nach ansicht des
astronomie teams nur die zitat spitze
des eisbergs sein möglicherweise
existieren in unserer kosmischen
nachbarschaft noch viele weitere
schwerkraft gegangen dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam es muss hunderte von
millionen schwarzer löcher geben aber
wir wissen nur von sehr wenigen wenn wir
wissen wonach wir suchen müssen sollten
wir besser in der lage sein sie zu
finden
ein polnisches forschungsteam hatte im
vergangenen jahr 2019 sogar dutzende
kleine schwarze löcher in unserer
nachbarschaft gesehen diese sind nur ein
paar tausend lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt entdeckt wurden diese schwarzen
löcher dass sie den weltraum stark
verkrümeln so dass die dahinter
liegenden sterne heller erscheinen als
sie tatsächlich waren die objekte die
für diese raum krümmung verantwortlich
sind aber konnten nicht identifiziert
werden gewöhnliche sterne scheinen somit
aus und lediglich schwarze löcher kommt
somit als verursacher in frage und es
gab auch bei einer von diesen
mikrolinsen beobachtungen die das super
teleskope in hawaii an dem andromeda
nebel vorgeführt hat voll genommen hand
gab es eine ist ein ereignis das so
aussah als würde ein planet vorbeiziehen
aber das war ein schwarzes loch das
heißt also auch blendet habe schwarze
löcher könnten im prinzip mit von der
partie sein
doch auf den ersten blick bleibt offen
warum diese sehr leicht sind und kaum
mehr wiegen als die erde sonne den
bisherigen theorien der physik zufolge
müssen sterne mindestens acht mal so
schwer sein wie die sonne damit sie sich
an ihrem ende in schwarze löcher
verwandeln doch dies könnte mit hilfe
von günther hasinger theorie erklärt
werden denn falls diese schwarzen löcher
sich nicht durch sternleichen entwickelt
haben sondern aus kollabieren der
urmaterie könnten auch sehr leichte
schwarze löcher das ergebnis sein
und dann gibt es eben noch diese
faszinierende spekulationen ob es nicht
sogar schwarze löcher von planeten
massen gibt also in der theorie kommt
kommen nicht nur schwarze löcher die so
schwer sind wie ein stern oder diesel
aygo schwarze löcher oder auch die
supermassiven schwarzen
die kommunale raus aber es kommen auch
welche raus die ungefähr so schwer sind
wie ein planet wie die erde
die werden nur ungefähr ein zentimeter
groß und da gibt es zwei phänomene die
wir jetzt gesehen haben dass eine es
wird im sonnensystem ein zehnter oder
neunter planet vermutet plane takes der
sich nur dadurch bemerkbar macht dass er
die warnende asteoriden irgendwie
sowieso ein schäferhund herum zu geben
scheint und nachdem haben wir jetzt
schon jahrelang gesucht und nicht ihnen
nicht gefunden und da gab es also jetzt
spekulation ob das vielleicht auch ein
schwarzes loch sein könnte
das wäre dann nur faustgroß also in
einem 10 10 erdmassen schwarzes loch
platz sechs oder neun wäre gar kein
planet sondern ein winziges schwarzes
loch und günther hasinger setzt sogar
noch einen drauf denn der astrophysiker
ist überzeugt davon zudem auch noch das
mysteriöse rätsel der dunklen materie
gelöst zu haben er ist der meinung dass
wir die dunkle materie schon längst
gefunden haben und zwar achtung in form
dieser schwarzen löcher seine berechnung
nämlich ergeben dass die gesamte masse
aller schwarzen löcher die sich im
weltall befinden in etwa demjenigen wert
entsprechenden fachleute für die dunkle
materie errechnet hatten ja also das ist
eigentlich mehr oder weniger der
ausgangspunkt dieser theorie dass man am
anfang des universums ein prozess hat
wohl direkt machen wird teile des
universums zusammenstürzen zu schwarzen
löchern und die würden gerade wenn man
jetzt das aus ist wie viel man braucht
um diese signale zu sehen also like oder
auch unsere fluktuation signal
die würden gerade so viel sein dass sie
die dunkle materie ausmachen können das
ist wirklich der absolute hammer
falls hasinger recht behält würde dies
also auch das ende der bislang
unentdeckten elementarteilchen bedeuten
die fachleute als eine der
aussichtsreichsten kandidaten für die
dunkle materie erklärt hatten die rede
ist von den sogenannten wilms hasinger
idee ist also das nicht bislang
unentdeckte teilchen für den
zusammenhalt des universums
verantwortlich sind sondern schwarze
löcher und genau die haben ha sängers
ansicht auch dafür
dass es uns überhaupt gibt denn erst
schwarze löcher haben demnach die geburt
von sternen und galaxien ermöglicht ich
bin absolut geflecht jetzt gibt es nur
zwei möglichkeiten die theorie bricht
wie ein kartenhaus zusammen oder ich
habe gerade einen zukünftigen
nobelpreisträger interviewt allerdings
ist letzteres nicht ganz
unwahrscheinlich denn alle bisher
erhobenen daten alle beobachtungen
bestätigen zusammengenommen seine these
ich bin erst mal absolut bach und kann
nur noch sagen bis dann bleibt dran